buenas tardes yo vengo a contaros una
historia que es una gran insensatez lo
digo completamente en serio si queréis
tener opciones de tener éxito en la vida
es mejor que olvidéis todo lo que diga a
partir de ahora bueno tal vez menos una
cosa el 70% de los jóvenes españoles
quiere ser funcionario o trabajar en una
multinacional por qué pues porque es
lógico porque no son tontos porque es la
forma más directa de tener una
estabilidad económica un coche familiar
en el garaje una casa con jardín la casa
con jardín se ha convertido de alguna
manera en la mente colectiva de nuestra
sociedad en el éxito pero he venido aquí
a hablar de otra cosa yo he oído hablar
del otro 30% esto es como en la película
the matrix os acordáis lo de la pastilla
azul la pastilla roja pues yo solamente
vengo a deciros la verdad es decir
enseñar la pastilla roja nada más
y la verdad mi verdad empieza hace
muchos años en un momento en el que
bueno pues yo trabajaba en una
productora terminamos un gran proyecto y
me quedo en paro como soy realizador y
periodista
he decidido hacer lo que haría
cualquiera no es contactar con mis
amigos del sector actualizar mi
currículum e intentar ver las opciones
que ofrece el mercado pero en un momento
dado
que no me quedo pensando digo yo siempre
pienso en qué opciones me ofrece el
mercado lo que caminos hay para que yo
los elija pero todavía no me he
preguntado en mi vida pero yo que quiero
hacer en la vida
y entonces hice un gesto que tal vez muy
sencillo que tal vez cambió mi vida
un folio en blanco
de a laxe y escribir exactamente lo que
posiblemente llevaba mucho tiempo
queriendo escribir escribir quiero dar
la vuelta al mundo en coche
y quiero hacer una serie documental ya
me fui viniendo arriba y quiero convivir
con los indígenas y lo vamos a poner por
todo el mundo y va a ser un gran éxito
en ese momento uno no ve entusiasmo que
se viene se viene más o menos arriba se
da cuenta de que se está liberando de
todas las opciones preestablecidas en
realidad que estaba haciendo dar el
primer paso fuera del camino
claro salirse del camino no significa
que tengas que salirte solo entonces
para poder llevar a cabo el compromiso
que acababa de firmar yo mismo con mis
propios sueños pues busqué equipo
entonces puse un anuncios y tipo
shackleton cuando fue a la antártida que
decía algo así como se busca un
productor y un cámara para dar la vuelta
al mundo va a ser un viaje duro exigente
pero va a ser la experiencia de tu vida
y tal hoy y sorprendentemente se
presentaron más de 200 personas
y bueno y al final elegir a un argentino
llamado alfonso negro un tipo que cuando
le dije te vienes dijo daley como si
fuéramos a la sierra un fenómeno el tío
con la cámara y un sevillano josé luis
feliú que llegó con toda la
determinación del mundo que yo caiga sé
de dónde vamos venga macho voy a vender
mi casa para el proyecto para hombre
para
y el tío vendió su casa para el proyecto
pero claro yo le dije oye no este que
financiarlo bien hay que hacerlo bien y
entonces estuvimos yo le dije que el
espacio hay que intentar bueno pues ver
cómo podemos sacar esto adelante' tan
despacio que nos llevó cuatro largos
años y en esos años
llamé a las puertas las conté en 303
empresas patrocinadoras posibles
patrocinadores coleccionamos 301 es y
dos si es
y esos dos si es consiguieron que aquel
folio en blanco se convirtiera en el
germen en el comienzo del viaje de
nuestras vidas
el viaje en sí os lo podéis imaginar
imaginaros una época dos años
absolutamente apasionantes no teníamos
por delante y teníamos toda la ilusión
del mundo y recuerdo que los días
previos a arrancar nos dirigimos a uno
de los responsables de la empresa
patrocinadora y en ese momento habíamos
comprado unas cámaras hd que por
entonces no era tan fácil comprarlas a
un precio módico y se lo dijimos muy
contentos digo allí vamos a hacer un
documental y demás y él nos miró con
cierto desdén y dijo pero vosotros que
os queréis national geographic o qué
a mí me dejó perplejo yo le contesté
pues claro que nos creemos national
geographic llevamos cuatro años
trabajando en esto tenemos el mundo por
delante somos profesionales si no nos
creemos national geographic ahora cuando
nos vamos a crear más en otro gráfico
pero aprendí que los sueños de uno
son muy difíciles de compartir mucha
gente podrá invertir en ellos mucha
gente podrá apostar por ti pero solo el
que está a tu alrededor es el que
comparte el sueño
bueno dos años cruzamos las estepas de
mongolia nos asomamos al cañón del
colorado y cruzamos el amazonas llegamos
a la patagonia es desierto de namibia
llegamos al narón goro nombre es
absolutamente sugerente es una
experiencia dura pero inolvidable y de
todos esos lugares hay uno que recuerdo
con especial emoción pero se trata de la
pequeña isla de diomedes es una roca de
hielo en el estrecho de bering esto está
entre rusia y eeuu y alaska
en invierno que era cuando nosotros
llegamos se congela y solamente se
congela el mar y solo se puede llegar
por ahí hasta la isla en helicóptero
y para llegar al helicóptero que llegara
a wales wells es la ciudad más
occidental de américa está bueno comprar
un mapa lo veis a tomar por por ahí
y nosotros estamos en fairbanks y dije
oye josé luís quieren dio su casa digo
esto te va a salir caro porque tenemos
que ir allí no sabemos si el helicóptero
no nos dejará subir para llegar a la
isla es una gran incertidumbre le dijo
aparte llegó a la ventanilla del
aeropuerto hijo así en su inglés
sevillano dijo
3 billete para wales y le dijeron pero
de ida y vuelta y entonces de verdad que
yo creí ver a un caballero andante que
se apartaba si la capa sacaba la espada
y dijo no sólo de ida
y yo me quedé pensando tengo billete
sólo de ida pero eso no solamente
representa el viaje que hicimos eso es
la vida que nosotros decidimos hacerlo y
en realidad lo que lo que se trataba que
el viaje era de un billete de ida porque
yo creo que en esta sociedad pensamos
demasiado en la vuelta tenemos
demasiados planes para una sola vida no
nos agarramos al refugio de nuestro
futuro y olvidamos el presente y
nosotros desde el momento en que yo
escribí el folio en blanco
pensé en presente en ahora en vamos no
sin pensar demasiado las consecuencias
ya os dije que era una insensatez bueno
las casas que llegamos a
wales convencimos al piloto llegamos a
diomedes
sufrimos temperaturas de 67 grados bajo
cero los esquimales acabaron abriéndonos
las puertas del pueblo para que os
imaginéis queda todo congelado era como
una máquina paralizada en el templo y en
ese momento yo me sentí feliz porque me
sentí libre porque había visto que
llegara allí era fuerte simplemente de
la voluntad y el deseo de hacerlo y
había que remontarse el día que había
escrito en un folio en blanco que quería
ir
en el caso es que la vuelta al mundo
siguió como os dije por todo américa
todo áfrica llegamos a españa y bueno a
josé luís no le quedaba ni el felpudo de
la casa al pobre que había invertido en
el viaje pero había que había que
rematar el sueño y había que conseguir
que una productora pues hiciera la
edición la postproducción siempre es
compleja la música la edición los
salarios y demás y conseguimos esa
productora y por fin dos años después de
regresar teníamos editada la serie y era
el momento de empezar a recoger los
frutos de lo que tanto nos había costado
salí de sacar adelante
y resulta que ocho años después de haber
escrito yo en un folio en blanco aquella
sentencia veo porque salía en internet a
las dos de la mañana
en nuestra serie se está emitiendo en
australia si está mintiendo en national
geographic
y el caso es que la serie se emitió en
130 países también en españa pero
aquello que debió de ser el momento más
culminante de nuestra carrera no
conseguimos emitir en nacional sí sí sí
nos creemos nacional geográfico pero
resulta que había algo raro lógicamente
digo porque no sabemos esto bueno pues
la respuesta es sencilla la
distribuidora dijo que ellos no sabían
que no podían pagar en definitiva nos
robaron la empresa
bueno llegó a la quiebra su empresa y
entonces pues nos quedamos sin el rédito
de tanto y tanto esfuerzo esa es la cara
venosa es la parte más roja la pastilla
roja de la verdad el mercado es
despiadado no van a compartir tus sueños
en tal caso se aprovechan de ellos a
partir de ahí nosotros entramos en un
estado de de potenciar está precariedad
de estabilidad económica porque era
siempre muy baja pero estable
y bueno lo cierto es que josé luís
emprendió sus propios proyectos y yo
persevere y dice lo que haría cualquiera
pues pregunte a mis amigos del sector
actualice mi currículo no había puesto
no tenía la vuelta al mundo y pues
estudie las ofertas del mercado y
entonces lo que hice fue
agarré otro forestas cervantes otro
folio en blanco
y escribí pues sabes que ahora quiero ir
a el pacífico y quiero el de japón a
nueva zelanda a hacer una serie mucho
mejor que va a tener mejor resultado y
vamos a meternos en las selvas de
indonesia
y entonces busque un equipo y puse otro
anuncio del mismo estilo que la anterior
y esta vez yo ya tenía la serie anterior
yo sabía que no iba a ser tan difícil ni
vamos a tardar cuatro años en sacarlo
adelante tardamos tres y medio
y después de tres años y medio
emprendimos aquel viaje maravilloso por
el pacífico y nos llevó efectivamente de
japón a nueva zelanda y atravesamos las
selvas más densas de papúa-nueva guinea
y recurrimos a australia en furgoneta y
la experiencia fue maravillosa
y volvimos a través de españa y esta vez
teníamos un producto que era categórico
y entonces la productora con lo que
habíamos hecho eso pues a su vez cedió
la explotación a una distribuidora y la
distribuidora lo distribuyó y yo un día
en casa me escribió una chica de
filipinas en facebook y me dice me
encanta tu programa soy fan se está
emitiendo aquí
otra vez no
y lo triste es que si otra vez también
pasó esta vez ya más armado de más
blindados a lo mejor jurídicamente pero
vamos no mucho más porque el mercado es
despiadado si puede lo hace nosotros
conseguimos recuperar en parte la
explotación de la serie de tal forma
porque no nos perjudicará tanto pero la
serie de sufrir una herida de muerte
porque había estado parado durante mucho
tiempo precisamente por este conflicto
y yo pensaba jóvenes han quitado todo
nos han quitado la ilusión nos han
quitado el trabajo pero no nos han
quitado el tiempo porque el tiempo es la
moneda de cambio para pagar las cosas lo
que cuesta un móvil lo que cuesta la
casa con jardín es el tiempo que nos
dedica a hacer cosas que no le gustan
para comprarlo y eso no nos lo habían
quitado entonces el éxito si le das la
vuelta tal vez será invertir el tiempo
en hacer el camino y entonces no habrá
ese objetivo y precisamente cuando no
hay ese objetivo uno se siente libre
porque yo sinceramente no creo en os he
dicho antes lo del éxito el fracaso yo
no creo en el éxito el fracaso creo que
esos son conceptos que es en la medida
que reflejas lo que el otro 20 tú te
sientes con más éxito y más fracaso pero
si creo en la felicidad y en la
infelicidad
y creo que bueno durante este tiempo
fuimos felices y creo que cuando uno
llega al final del camino de la vida
cuando sea dentro de muchos años
esperemos pues miren atrás y diga ua que
viaje tío
de eso se trata no
veréis yo después de último del último
documental cuando me enteré de que había
problemas dije bueno voy a hablar con
mis amigos en serio voy a actualizar mi
currículum ahora puedo voy a voy a mirar
las ofertas del mercado 3 a 3
tomando va a regalar los sueños que tú
quieras y para ti también
y en este pulso atlántico es maravilloso
podemos ir al atlántico hacer toda la
ruta desde áfrica occidental y américa
oriental irá al congo y la groenlandia
otra vez al amazonas
sigo perseverando y entonces cuando
alguien me pregunta
porque sigues empeñado en hacer esos
frescas a los dos veces tío entonces
bueno mira un poco atrás y tal vez esto
es lo que veo
veo que mis proyectos llegaron a lugares
que yo ni sabía que existía
y seguir tus propios pasos es la manera
más emocionante de afrontar la vida
si vas a tener que nadar contracorriente
para sentir el vértigo de tus propias
decisiones e incluso
vas a tener que lanzarte al vacío te
atreves a salirte del camino
lo más curioso es que nadie se
arrepiente nunca de haber viajado
conoces gente increíble y aprendes que
la verdadera aventura consiste en
confiar en los demás
y sabrás que has llegado cuando te
sientas perdido y no pienses demasiado
en el camino de vuelta así te sentirás
más libre
recuerda todos los sueños caben en un
folio en blanco
va a ser duro pero seguro te vas a
sentir atrapado le va a costar subir y
vas a caer muchas veces te paralizará el
miedo pero qué es la vida si no superan
el miedo nunca detener tus pasos
lo confieso no tengo una casa con jardín
pero cuando miro atrás siento que tal
vez viví el mejor fracaso del mundo